I don't understand is you know a part of
your message I've just you know I've
researched you today and hang on a
minute okay you know your big push is
that you care about men and you don't
think that men are getting enough of a
say hang on I haven't made the point yet
um because of feminism okay what I
wonder is when you start making calls
out like repeal the 19th women shouldn't
be allowed to vote how is that helping
young men because these young men have
women in their lives they have mothers
they have sisters they have teachers and
they turn around they don't know how to
act around women because you're giving
them license to be misogynistic I
wouldn't call it misogynistic I say be
equal so again men do all the feminism
well then okay I'd love for the
feminists please apply for the oil rigs
please go do the hard jobs in society
they're open they're hiring because I
don't equate for I I don't think men or
women are equal until we do the equal
work so